Scientists studying Antarctic waters have filmed and captured giant sea creatures never seen before.
They saw sea spiders the size of dinner plates...
...and jellyfish with six-meter-long tentacles.
They also filmed other unknown species of sea life. Here's more.
A fleet of three Antarctic marine research ships returned to Australia this week,...
...ending a summer expedition to the southern ocean...
...where they carried out a census of life in the icy ocean...
...and on its floor, more than one kilometer below the surface.
Huge diversity of life, very colorful, very rich far exceeding any  of our expectations.
The three ships all docked in Hobart on Australia's southern island state of Tasmania...
Their decks are full of an array of sea life, including unknown species of sea creatures...
...collected near the eastern Antarctic land mass.
The Australian Antarctic division expedition...
...will help scientists monitor the impact of environmental change in Antarctic waters.